[Musique]
comme chaque lundi de février nous
répondons à vos questions en matière de
finance personnelle avec nous ce soir
samedi la chapelle qui est indicatrice
financière indépendante bonsoir bonsoir
c'est très intéressant de répondre aux
questions à deux jours de la fin de la
période mais pour 2022 on peut continuer
à investir dans les réels
justement la première question de
Marie-Claire Tremblay qui nous dit
pourriez-vous m'indiquer les différences
entre le réel et le Célia
sûrement retenu que les cotisations
étaient déductibles du revenu imposable
donc ça demande s'il y a beaucoup de
similitudes différentes c'est vraiment
deux objectifs différents deux comptes
enregistrés dans les cotisations sont
déductibles et le rendement se fait à
l'abri de l'impôt mais dans le code
cilia c'est vraiment pour faciliter
l'accession à la première propriété et
le Real souvent plus associée à la
retraite et projets long terme donc pour
ouvrir un céliap donc ça prend 18 ans
comme une réa mais également il ne faut
pas avoir été propriétaire d'une
résidence le principal dans l'année où
on ouvre le compte et faut pas en avoir
habiter dans les quatre années
précédentes donc compartiment Montréal
les droites cotisation ne sont pas
calculées dans la même façon donc au
niveau du réel évidemment c'est en lien
avec le revenu gagné donc il faut
travailler pour avoir ses droits de
cotisations alors que pour le CIA c'est
le même plafond pour tout le monde qui
est de 40000 dollars les gens vont
pouvoir cotiser 8000 dollars par année
maximum donc ils vont pouvoir reculer
aussi d'une année à la fois si jamais il
y a du rattrapage à faire et
contrairement au réa pour le Célia vous
ne pourrez pas cotiser 60 premiers jours
de l'année suivante pour déduire l'année
précédente on ne prend pas également
cotiser aux Célia de conjoint mais par
contre on peut donner de l'argent sans
que les règles d'attribution ne
s'appliquent pour que le conjoint cotise
à son propre Célia c'est il y a beaucoup
de description sur le Cellia tenez-vous
bien informé c'est très intéressant ils
vont Morin qui dit si tout directeur
augmente encore le 8 mars prochain
est-ce que les impacts se feront
immédiatement sentir sur la hausse des
taux offerts par nos placements pour nos
placements par exemple les CPG
j'aimerais répondre oui mais
généralement peut-être qu'on peut
observer que le taux d'empereur augmente
plus vite que le taux d'épargne
lorsqu'il est question des hausses de
taux directeurs donc au contraire
finalement même pour les CPG à long
terme on voit déjà une baisse des taux
sur le marché qui sont disponibles donc
les banques nous doivent faire une
certaine gestion de risques et donc se
protège à long terme
pour les produits d'épargne à court
terme ça serait pas surprenant qu'il y a
une petite hausse de taux encore on
pense à des comptes intérêts élevés qui
sont disponibles sur le marché mais qui
sont pas nécessairement du plasma donc
rappelons que faut résister un peu à
l'attrait des taux alléchant pour la
laisser PSG par exemple qui devrait être
utilisé vraiment pour des projets à
court moyen terme et non remplacer votre
portefeuille à long terme même s'ils
sont rassurants dans des périodes comme
actuellement pierre bourrassa dit j'ai
regardé avec intérêt votre ENT Monsieur
François trains qu'on a reçu la semaine
passée étant donné que selon le propos
de Monsieur Traoré les marchés seront en
forte turbulence alors les obligations
sont-elles de bonnes pantoufles et pour
combien de temps samedi la chapelle
encore une fois ça serait un
portefeuille qu'on va dire équilibré
donc c'est vrai qu'en 2020 on était
déstabilisé parce que bon on sait que le
marché des actions a été très volatile
demeurer cette année et là cette fois-ci
les obligations ont été très décevantes
au niveau des rendements dans le
contexte de la hausse des taux mais avec
la fin de la hausetto qui est pressenti
on peut s'attendre à ce que oui les
obligations soient intéressantes à
inclure dans le porte avec l'eau dans le
portefeuille puis contrairement à ce que
les gens pensent le marché obligataire
quand même assez complexe il y a
plusieurs facteurs qui influencent le
rendement des obligations lorsque
actuellement les gens essaient de savoir
quel type d'obligation devrait acheter
dans lequel devrait investir et en fait
ce qu'on peut penser c'est que ce serait
les obligations à long terme à court
terme pardon 25 ans qui pourrait être
plus intéressantes mais encore là si vos
connaissances dans ce type d'actifs ont
limités je conseille plus d'avoir le
recours à un portefeuille d'action
d'obligation pardon qui est gérativement
qui va être bien diversifié qui va dans
le fond par le travail sur du long terme
et puis oubliez pas que si vous
surpondez riz le revenu fixe dans votre
portefeuille de façon temporaire ce qui
pourrait être une façon stratégique
d'aborder l'année 2023 mais faut quand
même y aller avec modération parce qu'on
doit quand même respecter notre
tolérance au risque et ne pas oublier
les obligations sur le long terme les
actions sur le long terme
Serge mirino j'ai 58 ans je viens
prendre ma retraite mon portefeuille
composé d'épargne non enregistrées de
réel d'un cri d'un Celli et des actions
de CRCD Desjardins je cotise
annuellement au maximum au niveau de mon
cellier de Montréal mais revenez à la
retraite seront composés du fond de
pension à prestation déterminée de mon
employeur et des revenus de mes
placements alors
recommande de convertir mon cri en FRV
afin de pouvoir faire des retraites
temporaires jusqu'à 65 ans est-ce que
c'est une bonne stratégie ce qu'il faut
comprendre ça c'est que le cri est un
compte de retraite immobilisé et qui
doit éventuellement être transformé en
fond de revenus viager comme le faire ça
permet de faire des retraites à des
retraits à la retraite mais ces
retraits-là sont beaucoup plus encadrés
l'idée étant d'assurer un revenu viager
donc dans certains cas on va utiliser
les retraites temporaires là des
immobilisations du cri pour faciliter
l'accès à des liquidités pour la
retraite dans le cas de Monsieur mirno
semble avoir quand même un portefeuille
assez diversifié donc la question qui
devrait se poser c'est est-ce que mes
autres revenus de retraite sont
suffisants est-ce que mes revenus de
placement or et air me permettent de
maintenir mon propre coup de vie donc on
aurait peut-être pas la même réponse
pour Monsieur Monsieur Serge et son
voisin donc vraiment le plan de
décaissement devrait être personnalisé
mais retenir que si on a accès à
d'autres sources de revenus en cas de
besoin de liquidité peut-être qu'on n'a
pas besoin de faire de retrait puis on
peut laisser les placements fructifier à
l'abri de l'impôt dans le cri on va
aller à la dernière question je le dis à
mes amis en régie la dernière question
qui est une petite vite vaut-il mieux
rembourser ses dettes ou remplir son
réel Sandy on fait les deux c'est une
question qu'on se fait poser parce que
les taux d'empereurs ont augmenté donc
est-ce que je devrais quand même que
quotidien à mon à Montréal donc quand
les crypto était beau personne se
demandait on devait être investir plus
donc on devrait pas investir moins parce
que les taux ont augmenté il faut se
payer en premier la retraite est
importante et je ne mentionne souvent
c'est difficile pour les gens changer
des habitudes on aime on préfère le
statu quo mais quand les taux montent et
nous paiements hypothécairement ce n'est
pas la préparation de la retraite qui
devrait écoper les vraies questions
c'est dans mes dépenses du questionnaire
ce qui reste après mon revenu les impôts
toutes les dépenses de base qu'est-ce
que dans le fond je peux sacrifier ou
diminuer pour maintenir un niveau au
départ pargne et me payer en premier
afin de faire preuve de prudence pour le
futur la suite dans Le Devoir vous
retrouve dans Le Devoir tous les samedi
merci samedi la chapelle
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]